avant de passer la frontière américaine
on réfléchit à ce que dans notre voiture
ou dans nos bagages mais faites vous
attention à ce qu'il ya dans votre
téléphone
est-ce que les douaniers américains
peuvent saisir vos appareils
électroniques
qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent regarder le
contenu on ne vit à l'heure actuelle des
douaniers américains peuvent vous
demander de déverrouiller votre
téléphone cellulaire votre tablette ou
votre ordinateur
si vous refusez de le faire vos
appareils peuvent être saisis s'ils ont
des soupçons
ils peuvent non seulement garder votre
appareil mais ils ont la technologie
qu'il faut pour copier contenu et le
partager avec le département à
l'immigration et d'autres agences
américaines qu'il refuse de nous
identifier
en un an le nombre d'appareils
électroniques fouillé par les douaniers
américains a presque doublé 2 octobre
2015 à mars 2016 8383 appareils fouiller
pour la même période l'année suivante 14
1993 avec ces fouilles
les douaniers américains font valoir
qu'ils ont été en mesure d'arrêter des
personnes qui possédaient de la
pornographie juvénile ou encore de
trouver des preuves de trafic humain
[Musique]
si les douaniers américains demandent
d'avoir accès à vos données vos options
sont limitées
par contre leurs pouvoirs sont contestés
gagne poursuite qui vient d'être déposée
en cour fédérale
si vous voulez qu'on vérifie quelque
chose